if you could only provide your daughter  with three tools for life and then  you disappear hypothetical scenario and  you won't be able to teach them anything  else but you could provide them whether  you taught them or they  learned the the map to master these  three skills or tools  what would those be okay one i'm taking  from my dad because this really helped  me  and he told me never use your illness as  an excuse  because if you use it as an excuse it'll  just destroy your life feeling emotional  is okay  if you need to have a cry have a cry  crying can make you feel better  and then the third one would be it  almost doesn't matter what bad thing  happens in your life  you can get over basically anything like  you'll get confronted with  disease and death and these these  horrible things  you might not have any money like lots  of things will happen but you have the  power  and the strength to figure out how to  get out of that and then to get to a  better place